let's play shaq first name
game who's ready to go i hope you are
big fella what's this first name
keep your eyes on the screen okay
charlotte hornets number six in the
league and three-point percentage
that is monk is his last name what is
his first name
oh my gosh this is a monk eli
monkey no that would be
malik oh
this one should be a little more up your
alley okay because of your
come on man with the sacramento kings uh
he's number two in field goal percentage
he's number seven in blocks
his last name is holmes his first name
is sherlock
what up what up holmes john
john rashawn hold on your clothes
oh man what number is he in what he's
not in a category he's not in the top 20
though
he is he's number two and field goal
perception okay number seven in blocks
oh here we move this is a youngster oh
lord
play some big city of
his last name is quickly his first name
is
they don't like playing bookies up there
giraffe you're right
quickly no it's it's so close
it's emmanuel quickly actually it's
spotted by jetta cattle
shout out to emmanuel quickly
this i i hate to do this but we're going
to stay with the new york knicks
and i think look this is a big man i
think you got a shot of this
he's number 20 in rebounds he's number
nine in blocks his last name is robinson
his first name is mister not david
robertson not big dog robson no
not cliff robinson nope i'm gonna go
with stewart
uh stewart also known as mitchell robins
mitchell robinson vancouver
if you missed those four you got no shot
at this last one
he's another kid
he's tenth in the league in three point
percentage
for the memphis grizzlies last name
first name is you'll get a lifeline
no well i'ma guess i'm gonna say desmond
somebody gave you a lifeline obviously
you just guessed that come on
what you mean somebody all stopped a
little information